this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream get free access to
nebula the new streaming platform built
by and for creators when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
[Music]
well governments globally are enacting
strict measures to contain the corona
virus raising questions about individual
freedoms and privacy rights during a
pandemic Netanyahu has caught for the
formation of an emergency Garmin South
Korea's takin similar steps by using
mobile phone and satellite technology to
track potential carriers Congress has
granted additional powers to president
without death to address the kovat 19
outbreak in the country the emergency
decree gives various powers including
the potential restriction of domestic
travel censoring the media but what
we're really concerned about is that
this location tracking this health
related information is going to be used
for other purposes particularly by
governments who are using surveillance
to track down activists or human rights
defenders or journalists or even
opposition figures you know what they
say you should never let a good crisis
go to waste
for would-be autocrats around the world
any chance to secure evermore
iron-fisted control of their country is
a good thing and the corona virus
pandemic is quite an opportunity what
better chance do you have of
implementing draconian laws than when
all your citizens are under strict
shelter-in-place orders it's no surprise
that some world leaders have jumped at
the chance to consolidate power but
under such dire circumstances are their
actions justified a deadly global threat
does call for an unprecedented response
but there's a difference between
unprecedented measures and unlimited
control the laws passed and powers
granted during crises are often hastily
reviewed or voted upon without much
deliberation and this can lead to
serious problems it's not uncommon to
see laws passed in response to a
particular crisis situation stick around
long after the crisis is resolved for
example Congress the White House and the
Pentagon have all been mighty busy this
week but what more do we know after a
week of shifting messages concerning
health politics and war today the
president signed a big new
anti-terrorism bill that would expand
the government's ability to track down
terrorists but at some cost
mr. speaker some of my colleagues today
will offer a bill to reauthorize the
Patriot Act it'll have the thin varnish
of reform on it designed to whitewash
the egregious constitutional violations
that have been going on the Patriot Act
was drafted in response to 9/11 it was
designed to make it easier for
intelligence agencies to gather
information on suspected terrorists with
the unpleasant side effect of allowing
drastically increased surveillance on
the American public that was back in
2001 it's now 20/20 almost two decades
later and were still stuck with it this
is pretty common once a population is
used to something they become
desensitized so what if the government
is spying on us right 9/11 gave the
United States in particular very useful
cover in expanding the power of the
state in keeping an eye on its citizens
what we're seeing with coronavirus is
much more widespread and shockingly
authoritarian the Philippines Israel
Thailand the US Britain Bolivia South
Korea and in the most brazen example
Hungary have all granted emergency
powers that would be unthinkable under
any other circumstance Israel's Prime
Minister Netanyahu has given his
security agencies the power to track
citizens using their cell phone data and
has ordered the nation's courts to shut
down conveniently for stalling his trial
for corruption South Korea who should be
commended for flattening the curve in
their country still implemented
incredibly intrusive surveillance
measures that will likely remain in
place after the pandemic passes in the
Philippines president Duterte who once
compared his country's constitution to a
scrap of toilet paper was granted near
limitless power to handle the corona
virus which is rather alarming
considering his track record of jailing
critics threatening journalists and
pushing for the return of the death
penalty to aid in his violent war on
drugs the Prime Minister of Thailand has
assumed the authority to censor the
media and journalists have been
threatened and sued for criticizing the
government's response to the crisis in
Bolivia elections have been suspended
another instance of convenient timing
because the upcoming presidential
election which had been scheduled for
May was going to be quite high-profile
the previous President Evo Morales had
been deposed in a military coup after
violent protests rocked the nation the
interim president has now consolidated
power ordered military police to
suppress large demonstrations and
intends to formally run for the office
sometime later in the year the United
States
I avoided new legislation that would
have allowed the indefinite detaining of
citizens without trial as well as the
repeal of legal protections for asylum
seekers even British leadership has
ended up with some very questionable new
powers including a two-year license to
indefinitely detain people suspected of
having coronavirus banned protests and
put 20,000 troops on standby which
supposedly won't be used for additional
policing while authorizing the detaining
of citizens based on suspicion alone is
very problematic what we're seeing from
Hungary is downright terrifying
Hungarian Prime Minister Viktor Orban
already widely denounced as a wannabe
dictator has finally found his chance to
snatch up all the powers he's ever
wanted our bond now has the power to
suspend already existing laws bypass
Parliament on new ones that he doesn't
like limit freedom of expression and
suspend all elections and referenda and
just to be safe he demanded these powers
indefinitely he is now ruling the
country by personal decree so there you
go that's how you get a dictator some
additional new legislation gives Orban
broad authority to arrest and imprison
anyone he finds to have distributed
distorted or false information as
defined by himself of course our bond is
perhaps the clearest example of a
politician obviously and successfully
dragging their country to autocracy over
the past decade the ruling party led by
Viktor Orban have waged war on every
institution that could challenge their
propaganda machine they took over the
majority of the nation's media handing
it off to one of Orban's childhood
friends they shaped University
curriculum to suit their twisted view of
history they've torn down old monuments
and replaced them with installations
honoring Hungary's interwar fascist
regime now after a decade of work the
transformation into an intensely
nationalist and as one Hungarian
philosopher put it post fascist Hungary
is complete our bond has secured total
control including a puppet Parliament
erased the actual history of the nation
and fabricated a glorious new mythology
watch what happens in Hungary the track
record of giving people like Orban
unlimited power is not very good but
there is a glimmer of hope some of the
Hungarian people have put up a sort of
protest art installation in Freedom
Square they've installed barbed wire and
placed shoes pictures letters clothes
and other items that belong to murdered
Hungarian Jews in the square as a
reminder that there is a more accurate
version of history and it's not what
orbán and his cronies are pushing
power grabs like those we're seeing in
Hungary are not uncommon in times of
crisis and if there's not a legitimate
crisis around when they need it would be
autocrats have no problem fabricating
one but whether real or fabricated
authoritarians often ride a wave of
popular support to their end goal of
absolute power take for example the
deadly apartment bombings in Russia in
1999 allegedly committed by Chechen
terrorists the bombings resulted in a
surge of support for then Prime Minister
Vladimir Putin which allowed him to
consolidate power and crack down on his
critics we've seen it all throughout
history
Hitler using the 1933 Reichstag fire to
stoke fear curb civil liberties and
enable the creation of the Nazi Party
the fabrication of a communist plot to
overthrow the Brazilian government in
1937 which allowed President Vargas to
dissolve the Constitution and establish
a dictatorship a failed 2016 coup in
Turkey leading to a two-year state of
emergency during which air to gan
tightened his grip on the nation and now
or bonds ascension to Supreme Leader in
part thanks to a legitimate global
health crisis the rest of the world
needs to take notice of how Hungarians
are standing up to Orban besides keeping
themselves and their families safe
opposing the spread of authoritarianism
is the most essential thing any citizen
can do in times like these and that goes
for people in any country not just those
on the brink like Hungary if the people
don't stand up to the lawmakers passing
draconian legislation that trampled on
their rights and essential freedoms then
there's likely no stopping them it's
always much more difficult to get rid of
laws that have become part of the status
quo like the Patriot Act so yes we need
to take unprecedented action to prevent
the spread of coronavirus but we also
need to be aware of how those in power
take advantage of crisis scenarios for
their own benefit it's up to average
citizens to hold their leaders
accountable and fight for not only the
preservation of democracy but also its
expansion when you see the power start
to consolidate in the hands of a tiny
minority it's time to speak up if you'd
like to learn more about the crisis
making these authoritarian power grabs
possible I highly recommend you check
out coronavirus race for a vaccine on
curiosity stream it's a nice short
documentary about the methods used to
slow the spread of the virus while we
search for a solution if you watch my
videos you'll know I'm a big fan of
curiosity stream it's an online
streaming service with thousands of
nonfiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game you can find tons
of great episodes like coronavirus race
for a vaccine and they've got a bunch of
material on technology and outer space
which are some of my favorites they're
giant catalogue includes
content on science nature astronomy
technology and lifestyle among others
unlimited access starts at just $2.99 a
month and as a special offer just for
you guys you can get a free trial by
following the link below
curiosity stream is available on just
about every platform you can imagine so
wherever you are you'll always have
access to great interesting content as
an added bonus
your curiosity stream subscription now
comes with a free Nebula subscription
nebula is a new streaming platform built
by and for creators like Wendover
productions real engineering Kurtz
Kazakh and of course second thought and
many others it's a place for us to try
new things and make original content
that just wouldn't be possible on
YouTube give curiosity stream a shot and
get free access to nebula when you visit
curiosity stream comm slash second
thought if you enjoyed this episode
consider dropping a like if not a thumbs
down while you're here check out some of
my other work I have videos on all sorts
of topics and I bet you'll find
something you'll enjoy remember to
subscribe if you'd like to see more
episodes like this one and click the
bell to be notified each time I upload a
new video thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one